on va parler tiens vous avez vu ce
député d'extrême droite polonaise qui a
éteint les bougies de ranuka au
Parlement avec un ex tu l'as vu ça
cétait polonaise tu le connaissez
celui-là oui non s tu le connais oui je
connais ah ouais oui il s'appelle
comment s'appelle Brown comment il
s'appelleos Brown bra
oui c'est bra celu vas-y vas-y faut
furieux tu sais que
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah vous avez vu ce qu'il a fait ouais
c'est terrible c'est un récidiviste en
mai il avait déjà frappé un historien de
la Choa c'est un petit groupe maintenant
o ils ont je crois 19 élus et ils se
singularisent par ça mais c'est ultra
violant il va être sanctionné R 2 ans de
prison c bien fait pour sa gueule
comment vous pourriez dire en regardant
Gill Vern en Polonie Gill tu te trouves
très beau et très très sensuel
g
oh j'ai truc pas bien
mince mais as dit ce que je t'ai demandé
PRS estce queoulez chacun quelque chose
en alors un truc gentilas envie de me
dire ou un truc méchant
ah je peux pas supporter ta
tronche voilà c'est mieux en polonais
qu'en français je TR un truc gentil ou
méchant c'est bien un truc gentil ou
méchant tu veux non tu préfèr lui dire
un truc gentil ou méchant lui méchant
méchant Méch tu veux un truc méchant est
que un truc méchant pourquoi tu
continues à avoir deux boulots tu as pas
assez d'argent c'est long ah c'est
méchant c'est long
je sais pas un truc méchant ben dislui
traiteele de traite moi une insulte
comme si je t'avais fait une queue de
poisson en voiture euh g ça veut dire
quoi pas une merde hein une merde merde
j'ai l'impression que
tui je j'ai l'impression que c'est ça en
fait tu tu te sens polonaise pour dire
exactement ce que tu penses des gens
icio qui qui veut oui tu'excites non
mais gentil ou
méchant gentil ou méchant tu veux dire
peux dire méchant gentil ou méchant
gentil ou méchant lui h est gentil ah ah
il a il a la côte hein tu m'excites mais
je l'ai déjà dit en fait
non mais si non mais si elle do pas dire
elle do pas dire c'est comme ça bah tu
es mon meilleur ami c'est nul c'est nul
quoi mon meilleur ami c'est pas Lori
connard je sais pas non mais c'est
laisse tomber il est nul Jean Michel un
truc un truc gentil je préférais non non
non d'accord non elle a pas envie tu
veux dire méchant bah je sais pas tu es
tu es aussi con qu'une
tub pas e mais c'est pas long Polska
c'est pas long ça as dit pas long c'est
pas long c'est pas long c'est pas long
palska ouais mais bon hein ouais qu j'ai
pas dit tu sais pas dire to en polonais
elle veut pas dire ça ve pas dire elle
veut pas dire Benaï gentil ou méchant
gentil ah bien quoi ça va elle aime que
Valérie et Guillaume quoi en gros ouais
non j'adore Gill ah enfin les autres je
vous aiment bien aussi hein non mais ça
va non je pas de te rattraper c'est bon
R
toutes les filles qui sont làbas bien
Gill c'est vra adore
[Applaudissements]
gore comment on dit en polonais tu es
vraiment plus es vraiment de plus en
plus
con que c'est pour toi
ou
RRE beocot
envie j'ai j'ai un trou pas grave pas
grave Mo bah j'ai un trou comme on
dit
M tu crois que ça va te servir ça il y a
moyen ça ser polne j'ai un trou merci en
tout cas vouz que je vous dise c'estit
une très belle séquence vraiment j'ai
trouvé queétait une très belle squence
d'amour et d'amitié qu'est-ce qu'il
aelle pas dit elle pas dit quelque chose
à vous en mé
méou monsieur est audessus de tout le
monde ahouais moi je suis chef va venir
quelque chose pouri on verra gentil ou
méchant vas-y
c'est pas c'est pas évident hein moi tu
crois que j'ai le temps conneries là il
un truc méchant c'est un peu de un truc
méchantas vas-y B choisis vas-y à [__]
moi non dis-moi je te tradu
choisirisois mais je vais te virer ou
pas
[Rires]
non polonais personne
com
merde on a le même mot viens dire on a
le même mot non non non l'air pire que
ça non non c'est un vrai ba je pense
c'est c'est un vrai ba tu pu du gland
mais elle est folle quoi mais attends
mais c'est une vous êtes choqué vraiment
non mais s rigoler non c'est vraiment ça
ho on peut pas le dire est-ce que peux
dire ce qu'elle a
dit tu pe dire m'attendais à tous
gre mais pour vous AZ dit ça mais il
vous a dit
[Rires]
quoiom c'est
vrai F
vousz non franchement je pense
qu' s'en FZ on passe dégradant pour vous
quand
même
tépectateurs attendz comme ça ou pas du
tout estce que c'est vraake c'est uneake
je sais
pasveêanchement c'est un truc de fou je
tpectateur pas comment
pens on a l'image est et beaucoup plus
de de compromis politiqu en attendant il
faut faire avec cette majorité relative
Emmanuel Macron il a dit alors du dîner
il y aura pas de dissolution pour
l'instant mais si on arrive à un impace
sur ce texte il fait quoi d'ici la fin
du Kinen il peut encore il a encore les
moyens Emmanuel Macron de faire des
réformes ambitieuses mais les réformes
ambitieuses ce seront des réformes
forcément politiques et les réformes
politiques c'est pas des réformes où le
et en même
temps les gars non non là là le canapé
est mort il y a plus de canapé je vous
dis le canapé est d
il se lève plus il part avec le
canapé je peux pas y croire les gars je
vous le dis ce qu'elle m'a dit
apparemment c'est passer au micro
puisque tous les téléspectateurs disent
on sait ce que tu as dit Paul on sait
pas alors alors c'est quoi ditnous si si
on le sait non mais je peux même pas le
dire partie vous pouvez dire moi
j'assume pas moi queux non du gland du
franchement d'où elle allit trouver ça
non c'est mais j'ai pas dit ça
mais toi alors mais si tu as dit ça
presque ah bah madame et sur le mot
presque bah oui c'est ça c'est ça mais
c'est quoi c'est quoi alors d'ù est-ce
qu'il pue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors les gars vous êtes
des c'esto C émission c'est de l'ention
il te parle non mais je pense arrête là
non ou mais sortez-vous non sans décon
elle est
F allez [__] de merde quelle séquence
de merde
euh non mais dans quelle émission les
meufs a pas il a part je parler deux
fois dans ma vie celle-ci sans déconner
il y aura des sanctions il y aura des
sanctions ou pas pourquoi vous restez
là mais vous êtes pas sorti là derrière
le rideau là-bas derrière le rideau j'ai
l'habitude allez j'ai l'habitude euh